If you're performing any type of
administration of an operating system,
whether it's Windows, Linux, Mac OS, or
anything else, you'll probably be
spending a lot of time at the command
line. In this video, we'll focus on the
Windows command line, and you'll
probably find some utilities that might
make your troubleshooting process that
much faster. Although there is a single
command line inside of Windows, you can
find that command prompt by going to the
search and typing in cmd. You'll see all
the options for the Windows command
prompt. One of the things you'll notice
in this list is you can simply open the
command prompt, but you could also run
this prompt as an administrator. That's
because there are some utilities that
will not run if you have normal rights
on the system. You will only be able to
run these utilities if you are an
administrator on that system. These
standard privileges will work for almost
all utilities that you'll use. But if
you're going to be making changes to the
configuration of the operating system or
modifying the way an application is
working, then you'll probably need to
run as administrator or with elevated
privileges. This gives you the
additional permissions that allow you to
make some of these critical system
changes. To be able to run in an
elevated prompt, you'll need to be a
member of the administrators group. To
be able to start this, you can simply
type in cmd and choose the option to run
as administrator. You can also right
mouseclick on the command prompt and
choose run as administrator. Or you can
use the shortcut control shift enter and
it will start the command prompt in this
elevated
mode. Let's try this on my Windows 11
system. We'll go down to the search
menu. We'll type in cmd and you can see
that the command prompt was the best
match that Windows found. For this
command prompt, we can open it, run as
administrator, open a file location, pin
it to our start menu, or pin it to the
taskbar. In this example, we'll choose
open to run it with normal rights and
permissions. And the window pops open
that shows our command prompt. Since I'm
logged in as professor, it shows us at
the menu
cusers
back/professor. When you first start the
command prompt, it's simply an empty
window. It's waiting for you to put in
the commands that you'll need to perform
the functions on that operating system.
But there are some prompts you can use
to determine what options might be
available to you. For example, you can
simply type in the word help and it will
list out all of the commands available
at that particular prompt. If you're
looking for help with a specific
utility, you can put that utility name
in the help prompt. So you can type in
help diir or help check disk and you'll
get a set of information that is
specific to that utility. Another
shortcut is to type in the name of the
command that you'd like help with and
then use a forward slash and a question
mark. That will also present the same
help
information. Let's try the help option
with our command prompt. We'll just type
in help and hit enter. And you can see a
lot of information scrolls down the
screen. We'll move back up and you can
see all of these individual utilities
that you could run at the command
prompt. Let's try a help that might have
something to do with looking at a
directory of files. So, we'll type in
help diir and hit enter. And now we get
the help that's specific to the diir
command. I'm going to press crl c to
exit out of that list. And let's try
looking at the same information but
querying it in a different way. We'll
type diir slashquest mark and you'll
notice that it displays exactly the same
information. We're just pulling that up
by using different methods at the
command
line. The diir command is probably one
of the most common commands that you'll
use. This displays a list of the files
and directories in a specific folder. If
you use the diir command by itself, it
shows you all of that information in
your current folder. But you could also
specify a drive letter and folder names
to view information that may be in a
different folder. All of the commands
you type in at the command prompt are
based on your current working directory.
If you're listing out files by typing in
diir, it shows you all the files in your
current working directory. If you need
to change the directory that you're in,
you could use the cd command or the
chdir command to change that working
directory. We often will change this
directory by using a backslash to
specify a deliminator between the
different folder names or between a
volume and a folder name. And there may
be times where we need to simply move
back one directory in the tree that
we're using. And to be able to move back
one working directory, all we would need
to type in is a cd dot dot. The two dots
together or two periods together refer
to the folder that's just above or just
backwards from the folder that we're
working in. Three more useful navigation
commands that we'll use are the make
directory, change directory, and remove
directory commands. These are the
mkdir, chdir, and rmdir commands. We'll
be able to use those to be able to
create directories, move into that
directory, and then remove the directory
once we're done. Let's try using some of
these commands at my prompt of C back/
users back/professor. That is the
current working directory that I'm using
on this computer. If we perform a diir
command, and hit enter, you can see that
there are a number of directories. These
are all listed on the right side. things
like contacts, desktop, documents,
downloads, and others. You can see they
are marked as directories. They have the
DIIR next to them. And there's a single
file that's in this directory. It's 95
bytes in length, and its name
is.acibility.properties. What I'd like
to do is look at what files may be in my
documents folder. One way that we can
move into that folder as our current
working directory is to use the cd
command. And since this directory is one
ahead of where I am right now, which is
under the C col users back/professor
directory, all I have to type in is a
space and the word documents. I typed in
capital D OC and I hit the tab key to
autocomplete that word. And you can see
it says CD documents. When I hit enter,
you'll notice now the prompt changes to
users back/professor back
slashdocuments. And if I use the diir
command now, you can see there is a
completely different set of directories
inside the documents folder. Let's say
you're starting a brand new project
associated with computer security and
you would like to store all of the files
associated with that project into its
own folder. To be able to do that, we
need to make that folder for the
security project. So inside of my
documents folder, I'm going to use the
md command to make a directory. And
we're going to call that directory
security. Notice I don't get any
response back when I hit enter. It
simply puts me at another prompt. But if
I type diir again and look at the
directories, you can see that I have a
new directory called security. If you
wanted to type in the entire path to be
able to create that directory, you could
do that at this command prompt as well.
For example, if you wanted another one
of these folders, but you wanted to call
it security 2, you could type in MD to
make that directory and then specify the
entire path. For example, this would be
users professor documents and then we
would call this security 2. Notice again
we don't get any type of response to
that command. We're simply put back at
the command prompt. But if we use the
diir command, you can see that there is
a new folder called security
2. Just as we can make a directory, we
can also remove a directory. And as we
use md to make a directory, we would use
rd to remove a directory. Let's say we
would like to remove that brand new
directory we created called security 2.
We will type in rd space security 2. And
if we type diir, you can see the
security to folder is no longer on our
drive. At the beginning of that long set
of folder names was a drive letter. We
saw a C colon right next to our users
professor folder. For example, each one
of the partitions on our computer is
assigned a drive letter so that we can
access it from our Windows Explorer and
from the command line. The primary drive
of your Windows system is usually
assigned the drive letter of C. If you
look at your Windows Explorer or you
look at the command line, you'll see
that we put that with the C reference
and then the colon to specify that we
are referring to the name of a drive. To
then specify the entire path, we would
use the drive letter and all of the
folder names up to our current working
directory. For example, we would use C
col/ users back/p profofessor to specify
that is the C col drive. We are working
in the users folder and inside of the
users folder is the professor
folder. You can see this visually if you
look at the file explorer inside of
Windows, it's this folder that we have
right down at the bottom. And you can
see that I have a number of options for
quick access at the top. We also have
one for this PC and a list of a number
of folders. And right in the middle is a
folder called local disk. And if I
highlight that and expand it, you can
see all of the different folders that
are contained on my C colon drive. And
you'll notice there is a users folder on
that drive. If I expand that folder,
you'll see there is professors and
public inside of that folder. If I
expand the professor's folder, then you
will see that there are a number of
files including my documents folder, my
downloads folder, and others. Let's
expand out the documents folder. And
inside, you'll see our backup folder,
our drive 102 folder, and our security
folder. And if we look at the command
prompt, that is exactly the same folder
names that we have under C back/ users
back/professor back/d
documents. In a previous video, we
talked about file systems that could be
used to create the storage areas on a
particular partition. For example,
inside of Windows, it's very common to
see the NTFS file system. There may be
times when that file system becomes
corrupted. There might be
inconsistencies in what we have in the
file system index compared to the actual
files that are stored on that drive.
This occasionally will occur because of
an interruption in power and the system
turns off or there could be a problem
with the drive itself. To be able to
check our file system and make sure that
it matches the files on the drive, we
need to run the utility check disk.
Check disk will search through our
logical file system. It'll look through
the index and compare that index to the
files on our system and make sure that
everything matches up properly from the
file system perspective. To be able to
run check disk, you simply use the
chkdsk
utility. And if you want check disk to
be able to fix any problems, you use the
/f option along with that command.
Because checkis could make changes to
the underlying file system, it requires
administrative access to be able to do
this. So when you run the checkis
command, make sure you're running it at
an administrator prompt inside of
Windows. If you're not only concerned
about the index of your file system, but
also the ability of that drive to
properly store data, you may want to
perform a sector by sector diagnostic of
the entire drive. One way to do that in
check disk is to use the chkdsk command
again, but instead of the slashf, we're
going to use slashr. This command
usually takes much longer than the
slashf because it will go sector by
sector through the entire drive, making
sure that every sector is able to be
read or to be written to. This is going
to also recover anything that might be
readable on your drive that doesn't
currently exist in your file system. The
slash r option is also going to perform
the same checks that we performed with
the slashf option. So if you're running
a slash R, it's effectively performing a
slashf and also looking at every sector
on the drive. One common thing you may
find when running a check disk on your
local drive is that the volume will be
locked. It will only be able to perform
this check function when the system is
starting up. This is exactly what
happened when I tried to run the checkis
command with the /f. It said the type of
the file system is NTFS but check this
cannot run because the volume is in use
by another process. Would you like to
schedule this volume to be checked the
next time the system restarts? And I
said yes and it confirmed that this
volume will be checked the next time the
system restarts. When I reboot my
computer, it will go through a scanning
and repairing process. You'll see the
percentages slowly increment as it's
performing its test. And once it's done
with the test, it will continue through
with the rest of the boot
process. When you perform the
installation of an operating system, one
of the first things it asks for is what
drive do you want to install this
operating system on? And once you select
the drive, it asks what file system you
would like to use on that drive. Then it
performs a format of the drive which
initializes the entire file system and
makes it ready to begin writing files to
that storage device. If you wanted to
perform that initialization process
yourself, you would use the format
command. This will format that
particular partition with a file system
that you specify. If you don't specify
any file system like I did here, it will
default to the FAT32 file system. You
can see that I use the format Kon option
here because the disc that I wanted to
format had the drive letter assigned to
it of K. The format process will verify
the size of the partition. format it
with the file system that you've
specified and at the end it will tell
you all of the information associated
with that format process. This format
command will only run if you are an
administrator on that system. That's
because format completely erases
everything that's on a partition. So you
want to be very sure you're choosing the
right drive whenever you use this format
command. And if you aren't quite sure
that you're choosing the right drive,
make sure you have a backup of the
system before running any format
commands. We talked about formatting a
partition, but what about the process of
creating the partition from the very
beginning? Fortunately, there's a
utility that combines all of these
functions together and more. This
command is the disk part command for
disk partitioning. You again have to run
this as an administrator command prompt.
You run the disk part utility and it
simply starts up and puts you at a
command prompt that says disk part. From
here you can list the volumes that are
on your system. You can format a
partition and run other commands to
perform diagnostics of those storage
drives. Let's run disk part. But notice
that we are running in a normal command
prompt. I'm going to run disk part
anyway. And since we're running as a
regular user, user account control asks
us if we'd like to allow this app to
make changes to the device. It specifies
that this is the disk part utility and
we say yes, we do want to run disk part.
Notice that the disk part utility now
starts in a separate command prompt that
is set up already as an administrator
command prompt. Inside of here, we can
run things like the help command and it
will show us all the options available
when running the disk part utility. For
example, there is a command to list
different items. We can perform the list
command and hit enter. We could list
disk, list partition, list volume, or
list a virtual disc. In this case, we'll
choose the list command. Let's look at
the volumes available, and it will show
us all the individual volumes configured
on the system. We have a volume zero,
which is assigned a drive letter of D
that is specified as a CDROM or optical
drive in the system. We also have volume
one. It's given the letter C. It's an
NTFS partition and it's 255 GB in size.
It's also a healthy partition and this
is the partition we use when we're
booting our system. There's also a
hidden partition. This is volume two.
That is probably our recovery partition.
And then we have a separate system
partition. This is a relatively small
partition that's probably used by our
BIOS. We can use the additional tools
inside of disk part to be able to gain
more information about what's inside of
those partitions or to format a
partition and clear everything out to
start
new. There may be times when you need to
take a file that you've created and
create a separate copy of that file. Not
surprisingly, the command to do that is
the copy command. Two of the more common
copy command options are the -v that
verifies that new files have been
written correctly and slashy which
suppresses any prompts when you want to
overwrite a destination
file. Let's copy some files around on
our computer. I'm going to start in the
directory users back/professor
back/doccuments
back/missions
back/pkx447. And if we perform a diir in
that directory, you'll see there is a
single file named
report.txt. I have a number of other
drives on my system and I'd like to copy
this report to one of those drives. We
will use the copy command. And in this
case, we're just simply going to use
copy without any extra options. We will
choose the report.ext command because I
need to specify the source of what I'm
copying. And now I need to specify the
destination of where this file may be
going. And in this case I'm sending it
to a drive X. So I will specify X colon.
And when I hit enter, it says that one
file has been copied. Now I'd like to
perform the same copy command, but I
would like to verify the contents of
that file after I copy it. Normally,
this would not be done unless we're
copying across a wide area network or to
a location where we're not quite sure
that the file is going to get there in
one piece. This confirms that we were
able to not only copy the file, but that
everything in the file was able to be
copied exactly as the original. To do
this, we'll use the copy command. I will
use the /v option in this case. And
again, we'll choose the report.txt txt
as our source and the X colon as our
destination. Now, since we've already
copied this file to that X drive, it's
going to give us a prompt when we hit
enter that says this report.ext file
already exists. Do you want to overwrite
this file? You of course have to be very
careful when answering this question
because if you choose yes, it will
overwrite that document. If you choose
no, it will not overwrite the contents
of that destination. And if you choose
all, it will overwrite anything else
that you've specified to copy in that
single command. We could be copying
multiple files simultaneously. For
example, in this case, we would like to
overwrite that file. So, we'll choose Y
for yes and hit enter. And one file has
been copied. But what if we were running
this copy command as part of an
automated batch file that runs at 3 in
the morning? We're not going to be here
to press the Y button to confirm that we
want to overwrite that destination. So
to be able to bypass that prompt, we
will use the copy command with the /v,
but we'll also specify /y. And then
we'll use the same parameters. Our
source is still the report.txt file and
the destination is still the X drive.
This time when I hit enter, notice that
we don't get a prompt asking us if we'd
like to overwrite the file. Since we
specified /y, it knows that we
automatically want to choose yes and it
copies the file and tells us that one
file has been
copied. If you're running a relatively
new version of Windows, you may decide
not to use the copy command, but instead
use the robo copy command. Roocopy
stands for robust copy and there are
many more options available in the
robust copy command than are available
with a simple copy. To give you an idea
of just how many options might be
available in roocopy, we're going to
simply type in roocopy and hit enter.
Notice that it says that for more usage
information, run
roocopy/quest mark. Let's perform a
roocopy with a slashquest mark. And
you'll see that pages of information
will go by. I'm going to scroll all the
way back up so that we can see all of
these different options. Most of this is
what we would expect. We are copying
from a source to a destination and
specifying a particular file. And we can
copy subdirectories or not copy
subdirectories. But if you scroll down a
bit, you'll see some very interesting
options. For example, you can throttle
the information as it's being sent so
that you're only using a portion of the
bandwidth. This might be especially
helpful if you're sending a large file
to a remote site over a very constrained
bandwidth. There's also options to send
the file and if there is an
interruption, it will begin to retry to
send that. So if you have an outage of
that network connection in the middle of
a copy, it will simply retry and retry
until it's able to restore that
connection and continue the copy.
When you start performing a lot of
diagnostics and troubleshooting and
dealing with multiple tickets
simultaneously, you might have a number
of different command prompts on your
screen, each one that's connected to a
completely different system. And if
you're ready to make a change to one of
those systems, how can you confirm that
you're really in the right window? You
don't want to shut down a computer
thinking it's one machine and instead
it's a completely different production
server. One way to tell what the name of
that device is is by using the hostn
name command. This provides us with the
Windows device name of that computer.
That way when you type in anything else
in that window, you know you're typing
it in on the right
device. So here's our computer. We have
a number of windows on our screen, but
there's a problem that we're trying to
solve back on this computer, and I need
to restart that system. But before I
send the command to reboot that
computer, I need to make sure that I'm
using the correct host name. So we're
going to type in host name and hit
enter. And it comes back with the name
deadless. And that is the name of the
host that I would like to restart. So
now when I perform any other functions
inside of that window, I really do know
that I am performing them on the Dalus
machine.
When you're troubleshooting a Windows
computer, you might be using Windows 10,
you might be using Windows 11, and there
may be different versions of Windows
within either Windows 10 or Windows 11.
So, what version of Windows are we
using? One way that we could tell is by
typing in the winver command, and it
will bring up a dialogue box that shows
us all of the information about this
version of Windows. So, here we are on
our Dalus computer, or what I think is
our Dalus computer. We'll use the hostn
name command again just to confirm we're
on the right computer and it is the
deadless system. Now let's determine
what version of Windows is running on
dead by typing in the winver command and
it brings up a box that tells us this is
Windows 11. Gives us information about
the version number and any other details
that we need regarding the licensing of
this version of Windows. Now we know if
we're installing a new application and
that application is expecting a certain
version of Windows, we can confirm that
before we even begin the
process. Now that we know the name of
the device that we're using and we know
what version of Windows is associated
with that device, it might be useful to
also know who we're logged in as on that
computer. One of the ways we can
determine that is using the who am I
command. The who am I command can tell
you what computer you're on, who you're
logged in as, what groups you may be a
part of, and other security permissions
associated with your login. This might
help you if you have a lot of windows
open and you're trying to run a command
and it's not running as you expect it.
It may just be that you're not logged in
as the correct user. And one of the more
useful options of the who am I command
is who am I/all, where it's showing you
more than just the name of the device
and the user who's logged in. It shows
you information about the user, their
SID, group information, any attributes
associated with those groups, and
privilege information all in one single
screen. This is a command you can run
relatively quickly if we use the who am
I by itself. It simply gives us the name
of the device and the user we're logged
in as. In this case, I'm on the dead
list server and I'm running as
professor. To get more information about
this username, I'm going to use the up
arrow to put who am I back into the
list. And I'm going to choose the /all
option. And you can see that it provides
us with a lot more information about not
only the username and the name of the
device. We get SID information, group
names, and all of the privilege
details. If you're working in an
organization of any size, then you're
probably going to have all of your
systems administered from one single
point. You're able to do this through
the use of Active Directory. This is a
way to have one central consolidated
database of all of your users, your
devices, and anything else that's
important on your network. One of the
ways that you're able to administer
hundreds or even thousands of systems
from this Active Directory domain is by
using a feature known as group policy.
This allows you to set different
features, functions, permissions, and
other settings on individual users
workstations. For example, you may have
a new group policy that you want to set
on somebody's machine that changes the
background of their system. Normally,
this is updated each time the user logs
in, but you may want to push this out to
the user in the middle of the day. To be
able to do that, you can use the GP
update command to force a group policy
update on a specific computer or a
specific user account. And if you want
to get more information about what group
policies are active on a device or user,
you can use the GP result command to
provide information about what's
currently
running. Here's a Windows computer that
is part of an Active Directory domain
and we're logged in as one of the domain
users, R McKay. If we wanted to see what
policies were currently active as part
of the Active Directory group policies,
we could run the GP result with a slash
R. The slash r is a shortcut for
resultant set of policies rsop and
that's a windows term that is simply
describing what policies are currently
running on the system. When we hit enter
it will query the system and if we
scroll back up this shows us the rsop
data that is for the sgc domain. It's
user r mccay who's logged into that
domain on the device with the name
deadless. And you can see it's a member
workstation. We can see the version of
Windows that's running. We can look at
information about the local profile and
it's specific to users R McKay. And it
gives us information about the user
settings. So we can see everything about
the way this user is configured in
active directory. And we know exactly
the last time group policy was applied
to this device. If we scroll down a
little bit, we can see that the applied
group policy objects are the local group
policy. So we haven't pushed down any
group policies from the central domain
controllers. and the user is part of the
following security groups. That's a nice
summary of information. If we're trying
to determine if this user has had a
certain policy applied to this machine
or this user, you'd be able to see it in
the GP result command. Administrators at
this system may have configured a new
group policy that changes aspects of the
desktop. to be able to push that policy
down. We could have this user log out
and log back in or we can use the GP
update command and we'll use the option
to force that change on this local
computer. We'll hit enter. It will
update the policy and we'll see what
changes occur by running another GP
result after the update is complete. It
says the computer policy update has
completed successfully. We're going to
get a prompt back. And now let's use our
up arrow a couple of times and run a GP
result. And you'll notice that a new
applied group policy object has been
applied to desktop background that might
allow or restrict access to changing
anything related to the desktop
background. When using Windows, there
may be times when certain core Windows
files are overwritten. This might be
overwritten by a third party
application. It could be overwritten by
an operating system update or malware
could have infected this machine and
made changes to the base configuration
of this operating system. One way that
you could tell if any of these important
Windows files have been changed is by
using sfc or system file checker. This
utility will go through all of the
important Windows files on your system
and it will check to see if any of them
have been changed. If there are
modifications to the core operating
system files, SFC will inform you that
that change has occurred. And you have
the option to tell SFC to correct those
files to remove any of those changes or
corruptions that might have occurred.
This can take a bit of time to run, but
if you run
sfc/scan now, it will begin a system
scan, look through all of those
important Windows files. When it's done,
it will give you an update on what might
have changed. And in this case, it says
that Windows resource protection found
corrupt files and successfully repaired
them. Details are included in the
CBS.log file, and it gives you the
location on where you can find the log
file to give you the details on what may
have been updated or changed in your
Windows operating system.